how's it going everybody it's Warren
many fans noticed that Iron Man in
Avengers in game seemed significantly
weaker than he did in Avengers infinity
war like most of the heroes in Avengers
endgame we didn't see Iron Man fight
until the final battle and when we did
see him fight he almost died at the
hands of Coll obsidian pretty easily but
luckily Spiderman was there to save him
and before then when it was just Iron
Man Captain America and Thor fighting
Thanos he got knocked out pretty easily
although it was Thor's hammer Mjolnir
that knocked him out so we'll give him a
little bit of a break there
but regardless it seemed like he was
having a much harder time fighting in
Avengers endgame than he did in Avengers
infinity war there have been many
theories and predictions about why Iron
Man was weaker and in game than infinity
war but now we have an official
confirmation and I'll talk about it all
in this video quick reminder if you'd
like a chance to win an Iron Man helmet
a Captain America shield and Infinity
Gauntlet or another Marvel Legends item
be sure to subscribe to my channel I'll
be picking three new winners soon so if
you caught the video that I did
yesterday you saw that Robert Downey jr.
in an interview came out and explained a
key fact about his mark 85 suit that he
wore in Avengers endgame now just to
clarify for those of you who do not know
the armor that he wore in infinity war
was different than the armor that he
wore in Avengers in game the armor that
he wore in infinity war it was the mark
50 and the armor that he wore Dan in
game was the mark 85 and that's really
important to note because an Avengers
infinity war Ironman put up a much
greater fight against Thanos than he did
in Avengers end game and the suit is
actually a key reason as to why Ironman
was able to fight against Stannis so
much harder in Avengers infinity war
than he was in endgame a couple of days
ago Robert Downey jr. in an interview
with the off-camera show explained a key
detail about the mark 85 in man suit
that he used in Avengers in game and
this is what he said the last suit he
has isn't even designed for him to be
able to survive using it the first suit
is all about will this get me and my ego
and my precious physical frame out of
this cave I'm in and into the desert
where maybe the cavalry can come get me
and bring me back to my stupid life
right right right the last one is not
designed to be able to
do its job and have you make it pass it
so just like I said in my video
yesterday and just like Robert Downey
jr. said in this video the mark 85 armor
that he wore an endgame was designed for
a very specific reason and that reason
was to be able to harness the power of
the Infinity stones and perform the snap
it wasn't meant for getting him out
alive
so the armour and defenses for the mark
85 Iron Man suit were not as strong as
they were in the mark 50 and that's
because they were designed for two very
different things remember Iron Man had
been preparing for Thanos since he had
his vision in age of Ultron he spent
years preparing his mark 50 Iron Man
suit to fight against Thanos that was
the sole purpose of that suit to fight
and defend himself against Thanos but
the mark 85 suit that he has an Avengers
in game was designed for a completely
different purpose in Avengers in game
Tony Stark has already fought Thanos and
he has already lost
Thanos one and performed the snap half
the population of the universe of all
living life got destroyed but as we know
Tony Stark after he fought Thanos after
he got back home after the rest of the
Avengers went and killed Thanos had
begun to secretly try and figure out
time travel when Tony discovered the key
to time travel after Scott Stephen
etosha showed up that wasn't his first
attempt at time-travel Tony had been
working on time travel over the past 5
years and during that time he knew that
he would have to go back in time and get
all of the Infinity stones and somebody
would have to snap everybody back and
during this time when he was discovering
time travel and coming up with his plan
he wasn't speaking to any of the
Avengers
so Tony assumed that he was going to
have to be the one to perform the snap
and that's why he built the mark 85 Iron
Man suit for the sole purpose of
collecting the Infinity stones and
performing the snap to bring everybody
back so that's why Iron Man was
significantly weaker in Avengers in game
than he was in Avengers infinity war it
was by designed his armor in endgame was
not designed to defend himself it wasn't
designed to fight Thanos it was designed
to perform the snap and bring everybody
back which is a great way to close Iron
Man story arc he goes from this very
selfish person in Iron Man 1 who only
cares about himself to this self less
person and Avengers in game 2 where he
sacrifices himself
for the universe and Tony Stark knew
that he was going to have to make that
sacrifice which is why he built the mark
85 armor to do exactly what it did
perform the snap so let me know what you
think about the differences in his armor
and Avengers infinity war and Avengers
in-game in the comments down below and
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway I'll be picking
three new winners at four hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof